hello everyone i'm sad omar i'm the
inaugural director of the yale institute
for global health i'm really delighted
to welcome you all to this event of the
global health conversation series
uh in addition to ygh which is our more
sort of
popular name
the abbreviated name of the year
institute for global health
today's event is co-sponsored by the
walker fund at the macmillan center at
yale
well as you know that the covert 19
pandemic has really catapulted the cdc
uh to the center of attention with with
daily news stories
um and everyday conversations among the
general public health who would have
thought that there would be
memes a lot of them positive
but not uniformly so on instagram
about the cdc or there would be um tick
tock videos um
you know uh
covering and talking about the cdc
well um with the focus
that is there on this government agency
today we will reflect on the work of the
cdc
including how this agency can evolve to
keep pace with the health challenges the
us and the world faces
and what it means to have the microscope
of the public
on
this institution's decisions
it is my sincere pleasure to have three
distinguished guests
joining us today
all of whom have uh are our former
directors of the cdc
and are um
and and i'll
esteem public health professionals
um
and i will introduce each of these
panelists uh in a second before i get to
that uh i just want to say that uh one
of our the directors uh
is having some technical difficulty in
joining so uh dr tom frieden may join in
the middle he may not be
uh sort of present at the beginning of
this session
so starting with the introductions uh
uh dr jeff copeland directed the cdc
from 1998
to
2002
[Music]
and and was a 26 year veteran of the
agency he has worked on virtually
every major public health issue
including infectious diseases such as
smallpox and um hiv aids in fact when i
was leaving
emory where i was before coming to yale
he gave me a bifurcated needle from the
smallpox program i don't know if you
remember jeff
as you know
as a gift
as a souvenir
uh he also worked on environmental
issues such as the bhopal chemical
disaster
and the health toll of tobacco and
chronic disease around the world
currently dr copeland is a
senior strategic advisor
for what's called champs which is a
program which is a pioneering program in
um assessing the causes of childhood
mortality around the world by using by
using innovative methods such as
minimally
invasive
biopsies and other similar approaches
and he's also the pi of the
international association of national
public health institutes
and the global health institute
china tobacco control partnership at
emory he founded the emory global health
institute in 2006
and served as the institute's director
and as emery's uh vice president for
global health until 2021 but i would say
the coolest thing about dr copeland is
that he's one of our own and he did his
ba from yale and and i forgot which
college did were you in um
i'll i'll ask you when
okay good wonderful and and served on
yale's board of trustees and he
currently serves uh on the yale
institute for global health's
advisory board um and we have uh and
continued to benefit from his
public health wisdom
the second uh
cdc director that i'll introduce is dr
julie governing uh again i'm going in
sequence of of their sort of
chronological sequence of their service
uh dr governing was also a cdc uh
director
um in 2000's uh um i actually have uh
you know you know so from from 2002
through 2009 where she led the agency
through more than 40 emergency responses
uh to public health crises she's the
executive vice president and chief
patient officer at mark where she's
responsible for patient engagement and
advocacy population health and and
similar tasks she joined mark in 2010 as
a president of mark vaccines and has
just recently announced that she'll be
retiring from mark in may 2022
when she will become the chief executive
officer
um of the foundation of the national
institutes of health that's a very
cool job uh i guess uh in this scenario
where uh undoubtedly like other public
health agencies
nih will evolve after and during the
later phases of the pandemic and there
is a lot of excitement around new
leadership at nih so in that function uh
you know i think i couldn't think of
anyone more
uh suitable to to be in that role who
has both government and industry
experience
the third director we have as our guest
is dr tom frieden he was the director of
cdc
from 2009 to 2017 and and had you know
look cdc director is a cool job but i
think in public health the coolest job
is the commissioner of new york city
department of health
it i i don't think it's a it's one job
that is
never boring i guess um and and so his
work made new york city's tb program and
overall health
overall health department's models for
the world
and his initiatives around tobacco
around trans fats
around uh you know
you know some of the other causes of ill
health were pioneering and were bold and
frankly controversial at the time but in
retrospect
of very well vindicated
uh he's he established before that
effective programs in india and improved
morale effectiveness and impact at the
cdc
he is now the president and ceo of
resolve to save lives an initiative to
prevent epidemics and cardiovascular
diseases worldwide he's a national and
global leader who has improved health in
the united states and around the world
and is one of the world's top experts in
tb tobacco control and health policy and
administration
so you know again
this is this is a highly abbreviated
version of each
of our guests introduction but it really
does give me pleasure to
to
have them come here
you know albeit virtually and engage in
this discussion as i said you know it's
a
forward-looking discussion
um about the cdc and u.s public health
so
the first question i have and the way
this goes is that i will ask you know a
set of questions and then in the second
half of our
conversation we will field uh audience
questions
etc
so the first question is a common
question from each of you and we'll go
in the same sequence starting with dr
copeland going to dr uh gerbening and
then dr frieden
the question um
dr copeland is that when you were
starting with you when you were the cdc
director what was the biggest challenge
you faced and how did you respond and
what were some of the lessons learned
from that experience that are
particularly relevant now and going
forward
i hope we have a couple of hours to
discuss uh
the uh
the biggest thing and dr gerbering knows
it as well as i am was heavily involved
um was the anthrax attack
uh the first time an an attack of that
scope and size
uh have been unleashed in the in the u.s
and even though
one might not that the number of cases
and the number of deaths doesn't compare
with the current pandemic
nevertheless it was a traumatic event
for the country it was newspaper
coverage front page every day for
weeks
uh it had
cdc working very closely with security
agencies in particular the federal
bureau of investigation the fbi
and uh the scary thing about it at least
to me
was not only were we dealing with a
difficult
lethal microbe
but we had human intelligence behind
that micro
uh and
makes it a little different from
naturally occurring events
um and in addition
it didn't take
many cases nor
much effort on the part of the
perpetrator to have the country in a
chaotic unstable situation around this
as a threat
so um
that was an unusual thank thank goodness
unusual event
and one that
seemed to grind to a halt of its own
accord
so because when we uh basically had
finished our investigation and we're
we're still involved in parts of it
nevertheless there were no new cases
occurring nor signs that the perpetrator
was
off doing other things it reminds me
however of a common question all of us
have been asked at some time which is
uh are we prepared
uh you know that for what
it usually isn't modified would you say
we're prepared for public health threats
well it really depends on prepared for
what
are we being prepared for
five letters in five mailboxes and a
couple of locations
or are we prepared for
hundreds of letters uh and
hundreds of locations where they're
deposited and an ongoing threat that
doesn't stop
it's there's a big difference in
response and and um
the threat that that poses to many
aspects of the country's existence
things learned from that
um
one is that you can't be over prepared
that
what strikes next
may have characteristics that are very
difficult to either
categorize explain or control
and yet we need to be as prepared as
possible
uh but that includes a work you know and
we'll get into this more uh that
in in something of a colossal
nationwide and then worldwide threat
um having a workforce that's adequate to
meet that and the wide range of skill
sets that are needed for it is difficult
and uh very few places have anything
approximating such a workforce
in addition
preparation includes mock exercises
role playing
and
those that were held were very helpful
and very useful
but that needs to be an ongoing feature
in terms of
other
aspects of it that we can learn from
the need for a skilled talented
dedicated workforce
emanating in at the grassroots level in
counties in small cities and townships
and moving up through
state health departments
and then governmental federal
governmental institutions
that
interface between those different levels
is crucial in control of an outbreak of
almost any kind
wonderful dr
governing just build on jeff's um
comments and and by the way hello from
south dakota i am having a little bit of
connectivity challenges here in the
hinterlands so please forgive me if i'm
fading in and out
um you know i i think our tendency is to
gravitate toward the infectious disease
emergencies or these uh urgent public
health crises and i'll say a bit about
that but i actually think the hardest
thing for me
as the director was balancing those
urgent imperatives with the other health
threats that plagued people on an
ongoing basis
we came into the cdc in the middle of an
hiv pandemic
we had dealt with an obesity pandemic
that continues to be a global health
threat so i think
you know the the challenge for
leadership is how do you make sure that
you don't neglect the important issues
that are long-standing and
go so far in the direction of the acute
crisis that you really create a public
health system that can't fulfill the
entirety of its mission and that's not
just a challenge at the cdc we are a
system
we have to include our states our
counties our local
territorial and tribal health
departments in this conversation as well
as multiple partners outside of those
organizations and when we're talking
about preparedness or challenge it
really i can't think of a single
challenge that we experienced at cdc
that wasn't also a challenge on the
front line of public health somewhere
else so
that's a really hard situation i'm sure
tom will have more to say about that
because he's been on both sides of that
equation but for me personally i think
clearly anthrax was an incredible stress
test but it helped us get ready for the
next big threat we faced which was the
first sars outbreak in 2003
and fortunately cdc really i think
exemplified the learning organization
under the leadership of the national
center for infectious disease as well as
dr copeland when we established a whole
array of after-action reviews with
virtually every set of stakeholders that
you can imagine from law enforcement to
hospitals to college presidents and so
on and so forth really to learn and
listen to the um panoply of stakeholders
that needed us to be supportive and
helpful and provide some coordinating
leadership
so that that
outbreak when we were walking into it
was very ominous because if you recall
the mortality rate from sars was about
10 percent
and we were seeing it globalize
overnight
on the
in the respiratory tract of a handful of
travelers that had all stayed in one
hotel in hong kong
and from there
nosocomial transmission as well as some
significant community transmission in
some cases mysterious community
transmission for example in a in a
residential facility in hong kong where
i think to this day we don't exactly
know how the people were infected
so um many um examples of how we had to
learn on the fly
make decisions with insufficient data
and when i've been watching cdc and the
public health system in the context of
our current pandemic i
i i think one of the biggest lessons i'm
reminded of is that what you see on the
outside and what's above the fold on the
newspaper does not tell the whole story
about what's going on across our entire
public health system there are
absolutely heroic
decisions being made heroic
data being gathered and translated and
promulgated
guidance documents that are addressing
some of the most specific needs
that again don't always make the
controversial front page but are
actually important to different sets of
stakeholders so i you know as we talk
about how to make the cdc or how to make
our public health system stronger we
should also make sure to be mindful of
the strengths that it does have and make
sure we don't inadvertently
um diminish those while we are trying to
solve some of the longer term structural
financial and workforce challenges that
we face in the in in the modernization
imperative i think is how i would put it
so i'll stop there and and you know as i
said i'm sure tom will be able to
balance the cdc view with the new york
city local view
thanks so much well i agree with
everything uh both dr copeland and dr
gerberting have said and i really
appreciate the last point dr gerbing
made which is it's it's easy to
criticize and it's often hard to do
better and it's very important when
we're thinking about
public health meaning the public sectors
public health program to realize what
are the constraints they work within and
what's the art of the possible in terms
of public health i'm going to mention
two challenges that i faced one was the
ebola epidemic and that was massive i
remember at one point speaking to the
incoming eis officers and one of them
asked what percentage of your time is on
ebola and i said well i don't know
exactly but it's certainly above 90
percent and and that was the case for
you know months
when uh there was a case of ebola in
lagos nigeria that was the scariest
moment of my seven and a half years as
cdc director because if it had gotten
out of control in lagos it would have
been all over nigeria all over africa
not just for months
possibly for years and not just killing
people from ebola but shutting health
systems so
i remember putting my hand on the
shoulder of one of our top
control experts and saying you will be
on the flight to lagos tonight and he
was and we pulled all of our polio staff
and a number of other staff there and
the team did a fantastic job the
nigerian team did a fantastic job based
on really the polio infrastructure and
the field epidemiology workers and they
stopped the outbreak they stopped what
would have been a huge disaster
uh
a couple of months later we had a case
in the u.s that wasn't promptly
diagnosed we had contacts one of whom
flew and it was a real mess
uh you know we we came in for heavy
criticism
um not every decision we made was
perfect absolutely we made mistakes uh
but we made the best decisions we could
based on the data that we had and
i think that the
information that we conveyed and the
lesson that we learned is that
communication is absolutely essential
tell people what you know when you know
it how you know it tell them what you
don't know and what you're doing to try
to find it out and give them practical
concrete things they can do to protect
themselves their family and their
community these are the principles that
jeff and julie wrote and we inherited as
the principles of emergency health
communication be first be right be
credible be empathetic
be respectful give people practical
proven things to do because if you don't
give them practical things to do they
will do other things that aren't very
practical
yeah the second broad area
it was tobacco control and here this is
what kills the most americans and we
were able to run hard-hitting ads
we were not able to get the food and
drug administration to take some of the
regulatory action we wish they had but
if i can i'll just end with four big
lessons one speed is really important
in ebola in liberia we established
something called the rapid isolation and
treatment of ebola or the right strategy
and we found that if we could intervene
in
days hours and days instead of days and
weeks we could stop every chain of
transmission within three generations
within a month or two if we didn't it
might go on for six or twelve months
second key lesson is flexibility of
funding cdc is hamstrung 150 different
budget lines i had literally 20 times
more flexible dollars as new york city
health commissioner than i had as cdc
director and when ebola hit it happened
to be the end of the fiscal year and we
actually had to borrow three million
dollars from another agency to pay plane
tickets because we didn't have that kind
of flexibility third is the global
nature of public health a risk anywhere
is a risk everywhere we can't pull up a
moat and certainly covet 19 shows that
and fourth the importance of policy
change policy change is the royal road
to progress and whether that's clean
water and clean air or that's
rapid data modernization or that's uh
any policy aspect of public health it's
very important to keep that in mind i'll
stop there
well thanks this is wonderful and i was
i'm just going to say that you know you
the the playbook gear you all wrote we
teach uh that playbook communications
playbook it's it's out there
um and and i wish this was
more widely used especially in this
pandemic you know at various levels um i
will uh sort of switch things around a
little bit because we're getting a bunch
of questions a lot of questions so i
will go to an audience question uh and
uh
dr copeland
this one is to you into continuing the
some of the points that dr frieden
brought up
you know as you know
what do you think about how do you work
with cdc's washington dc office to
advocate
for and enact public health legislation
uh or public health policy obviously cdc
is an atlanta based organization for
those
of us who don't know it it's very much
enmeshed in the in the overall fabric of
that city
etc obviously it's a federal entity
um
but it's not a washington dc entity
which
frankly has been leveraged fairly
successfully by a lot of leaders by
making sure that there is a bit of a
separation
uh between the political arm
of the u.s government and the sort of
the technical arm of the us government
but setting that aside
that has another dimension about the
sort of the dc office and how
you know what are some of those dynamics
that can be leveraged
dr copeland
thanks sir
um
there's been a lot of discussion about
this over years
that you know that it's bad to be away
from dc because that's where all the
political action is the other person
says it's great to be away from dc
because we're immune from some of the
politics that goes on there that's not
helpful to us the bottom line is you
need both first of all
if you if you were to want to move cdc
somewhere today
you'd have a lot of bricks and mortar on
your hands
as to where to put it
and you have lose you'll be losing an
extraordinarily talented workforce that
is in place and i think largely thrives
by being a bit more distant from the
world of politics having said that
leadership at the center and in the
department of health and human services
needs a close interface with cdc
leadership so there's a washington
office and i think it's developed
considerably over the years and makes a
big difference that their
folks that are there have often been on
the hill before
uh know a number of people and can
cultivate
uh a
bipartisan approach
to health and public health uh that's
really vital if we're going to be
continuing to improve
our outcomes versus the various diseases
that threaten us
having friends in the in the legislative
branch of course in the executive branch
are really important and it and that
means they need to be knowledgeable
about what we do and knowledge about
public health
i think one of the problems we are
dealing with right now
which is a
unfortunate
drop in respect
for science in general for scientific
institutions
for the people that work in them
is disastrous for the well-being of the
country
that's not where growth is and growth
and discovery and application
uh are what counts so and for that to
work
the the relationship with government
isn't going away
we need to
inform
and encourage engagement of elected
officials in what we do at the state and
local and federal level
and to have them as partners moving
ahead
with all the different pieces that
my colleagues have described whether
their chronic disease is
non-communicable environmental
occupational as well as infectious
all those need
the support from the hill
the folks in atlanta do better when the
folks in washington the elected
officials and the appointed ones
in having respect for public health
enthusiasm for what it's
accomplished and contributes
and
become partners with us and that that's
occurred regularly over the decades of
the cec
some elected officials in the house and
senate
and
take such pride in what cdc does but
they've played a role right alongside us
in getting things done
and i think
we'd all love to see
partners like that again
wonderful uh dr dr gerberting um
when you were the cdc director there was
a pretty substantial reorganization
effort to improve
um sort of the the functioning of cdc as
an overall
uh organization but with a specific
focus on improving preparedness from uh
various threats
um
nearly two decades later later and in
light of recent events
um any thoughts on further restructuring
or any lessons
that you can look back to words that can
inform
cdc's future and broadly public health's
future in the us
i'll just start by saying something that
jeff brought up in the beginning and
that is that um anthrax taught us a lot
um it taught us scale it taught us you
know intense pressure and visibility it
taught us the globalization a lot of
people don't know that some of the mail
that was contaminated with anthrax
spores ended up in the diplomatic
courier pouches that went to a number of
embassies around the world that was kind
of out of the news but something that
was certainly on our mind at cdc at the
time and so um
you know the sequence of events it is
hard to go back in time to 9-1-1 and
then the anthrax attacks that followed
shortly after and
recall the mindset
we had no reason to not believe that
anthrax was somehow related to the 911
attacks so that did flex the apparatus
of public health as well as our entire
government in a direction that was much
more focused on the what-if scenarios i
think the good part of that is that we
did make some substantive investments
that have had staying power and have led
to
broad improvements in our public health
preparedness across our network
but the challenge
is sustainability of effort
investment and
basically leadership intent and we often
characterize these decades as
periods of boom or bust or
complacency to crisis to complacency to
crisis
so you know restructuring is not the
solution to anything that i've ever
experienced i think that
sometimes restructuring can result in
efficiency or it can create
opportunities to bring in a different
kind of talent or rearrange people but
basically the kinds of things that are
really necessary to build a prepared
nation
are
some structural issues certainly
budgetary issues that tom has already
mentioned
and i think authorities also come into
this you may not realize that basically
cdc has essentially no authority to
determine what happens in a state or a
community health department and yet
to really have an effective cascade of
protection whether we're talking about
emergencies or chronic problems we have
to have a much greater degree of
harmonization integration of our data
systems which currently are you know
about as
integrated as a children's sandbox and
we really um have not been able to solve
for these foundational
changes that are necessary to truly
modernize not just cdc but the whole
network that has to
come into play we saw this in the
pandemic where we couldn't get in real
time the hospital information or when we
couldn't really get vital statistics
data and i'll refer you to other
resources on that but the failure to be
able to report the mortality from the
pandemic is not because people in
atlanta didn't want to do it it's
because the whole network has to
contribute data in a uniform way and we
had until the emergency declaration was
called we had no authority to do that so
there are some very specific authorities
and we have to start considering
are we at a point in our evolution where
we need a national public health system
not a network of 3000 plus
independent entities
that cooperate but not necessarily in an
efficient or timely manner
yeah i think i think it makes a lot of
public health sense to at least think
about this obviously it will have pretty
substantial legal and even
constitutional implications perhaps the
tenth amendment would come into play in
this conversation but i think there are
still some things we can do
um because we all want the same thing
and when it's the right thing to do you
know we we have to think that how do we
reshape policies so that we can do the
right thing
yeah well this is wonderful so so dr
freda the next question from you again
it's from one of the actually one of the
reporters in the audience
and they want to know you know
do you think the use of title 42 is
still justified
in the current public health context and
is it appropriate now that the
order has ended for unaccompanied minors
for it to continue to apply to families
and adults arriving in the u.s borders
i don't want to comment on the policy
issue there
uh i i thought you were asking about
title 42 hiring which is a mechanism by
which cdc is able to pay competitive
salaries and that certainly needs to
continue
uh but that's a hiring policy i think
the broader issue is
um how do we in public health
keep faith with the american people how
do we make clear that the decisions that
are being made are made
based on
both the science and the policy
implications
i think there's kind of a
misunderstanding of certain things
when you say follow the science
yes the science will lead you so far
but the science ends where a community
makes a decision
and that decision might be made
differently in different communities so
at the same let's take covet as an
example at the same level of coveted
transmission in one community that
community may decide you know we really
are concerned and we're going to shut
restaurants bars and churches and other
houses of worship uh until it gets to
this level another community may decide
you know
our churches are so important to us
we're going to keep the churches up
another community inside our bars are so
important to us we're gonna keep those
open but but fundamentally
it's not just a question of
science it's a question of science and
policy and cdc can inform the science
but cdc doesn't set policy it's the us
government that says policy
and i i think
if i can reflect on what's happened over
the past five years
there was an inappropriate
interference with cdc science in the
prior administration to the extent of
folks at hhs writing things on the cdc
website to be posted as if they were cdc
documents that's really inappropriate
that's you know i i said in one
forum that's the equivalent of writing
graffiti on a national monument
but somebody says you know if you write
graffiti corrected me and said if you
write graffiti on a national monument
people know it's graffiti here people
didn't know it was graffiti
so so yes there's certainly an
inappropriate policy involvement but it
doesn't mean that cdc sets policy cdc
informs policy with science and then a
policy decision is made
um if that policy decision is so
divorced from where the science leads
people at cdc may object they may quit
they may leave but generally the way
policy decisions are made is there's a
give and take and then a decision is
made and then people get on board to to
implement but for the specific issues
with immigration i think we need to see
more rapid change with things like
travel guidance
and
the issues are tough these are tough
issues i can tell you
when
ebola
there was a case in the u.s second case
in the u.s it was october 2014 the
height of the midterm elections it was
highly politicized calls for travel bans
very very difficult to work rationally
in that environment
yeah no i think i think that that's
that's a really great point um dr
copeland um you know i know that you you
know you've worked extensively around
the world
and you have engaged with collaborators
uh in china fairly extensively and in
this current environment
which is
increasingly
antagonistic um
between you know there's no other way to
describe it between these two great
powers
what are some of the implications of of
this kind of friction on global health
and what is the way forward
and both in the context of this pandemic
it really sort of surprises me
that uh you know the us the engine of
scientific research and innovation and
china
the engine of manufacturing have this
non-alignment of uh you know mutual
self-interest it seems or um
when it comes to collaboration around
this pandemic irrespective of what else
goes on
uh in terms of their own uh sort of
domestic and and foreign policy
priorities any thoughts on that
yes um
cdc has a history
of um
of globalization if you will of worrying
about
diseases that arise in a different part
of the globe and our threat to spread
and that there's value in having a
working relationship with every
geopolitical entity around the globe
because you don't know where things are
going to start or where they're going to
end up
and i think that our philosophy of
there's no written uh bible on this
thing is is that
work with people who are like-minded
with us
and who have something to gain
uh from
making improvements in health and health
care
uh around the world and whether in past
decades it was
the koreas it was um cuba
uh it was russia at different times etc
but uh in terms of interface with china
we work closely with them for
30 plus years
uh and we work with people who have
every bit the same sincere concern
desire to improve their health of them
cells their families their communities
their neighborhood as we do and have
things to offer us
that improve what we do and we have
things to offer them that improve what
they do
so um
there are wrinkles in this uh we're not
we're not immune or oblivious to what's
going on around uh and that's
unfortunate there's more to be gained by
these two great powers than not um but
that's well beyond our our um
tasks our responsibilities we can only
do what we work in when it comes to
working in public health we have a long
track record of working together coming
up with
um solutions to problems improving the
health of people's there and improving
the health of peoples here but you know
for the next pandemic if we go into this
thinking they're they're our
enemies or we're they're hostile after
we're hostile then that may be true in
some
political layers of the of the fabric of
life but in terms of
scientists
public health workers themselves
many have been here we know each other's
families we work together
we're not naive we know that problems
can go on even in these settings
but we stand to lose much more than
we stand to
gain
if we don't find ways to work together
and and it will pay off
soon
or later but it pays off to have these
uh common
uh partnering
partnerships uh in public health
so uh governing you have a unique
vantage point you you have led a premier
um or the premier in this country public
health agency but also have been in the
corporate sector pretty uh you know for
past several years
and one um
you know issue i know mark is not
engaged in those debates
uh but one issue has been global vaccine
equity
um any thoughts on how we ensure
that in the next pandemic
we build
systems and we build public-private
partnerships
that ensure
global equity in in vaccines and and i
know mark has uh made
certain commitments of um
of making uh you know some of the
treatments available earlier on uh
through technology proactive technology
transfer etc but broadly speaking rather
than sort of
from the vantage point of a single
company what can be can be the
structural triggers
policy makers can put in place
so that
we have a more equitable response
in terms of uh vaccines and treatments
the next time around
now i'm really worried about it um i i
don't think it's going to be an easy
solution set
you know what we have observed in the
pandemic is well-intentioned
statements and commitments that fall by
the wayside when the reality of the
urgency of the
national demand takes precedent we've
certainly seen that in the countries
that are making vaccines
i think perhaps one of the most poignant
examples was serum institute of india
who had promised a significant number of
doses to covax the international
consortium to try to improve access to
vaccines and then the indian government
made the hard decision that with the
delta outbreak there that they had to
prioritize the allocation of that supply
locally
there are some who believe that having
many more
sites of vaccine manufacturing in many
more countries around the world would be
part of the solution and i don't
disagree with that but i'm very familiar
with the scarcity of
the resources both human as well as
technical resources necessary to
manufacture a vaccine and i'm also well
aware of how hard it is to do it
if it was easy we would have solved it a
long time ago
all you have to do is look at the
situation not in an international
setting but in maryland when emergent
biologicals was unable to successfully
produce the johnson johnson vaccine
without encumbering several
quality issues so
this is
an area of science that's not for the
faint-hearted over the long haul we do
need to have a more global
network of vaccine supply and i hope
that the platform technologies will make
that easier although i'm not too
optimistic that will happen fast people
are naive in in how they assess the
probability for that
but i also am concerned that our
international institutions are not
strong and we need global leadership
from the have countries um to be
inclusive of the have not countries so
to speak
and much stronger commitments through
the g7 the g20
the governmental alliances and i would
like to think that the one of the
lessons we've learned is that we are
only as safe as
the world is safe and so it's an
enlightened self-interest to try to do
more to create a back equitable vaccine
solution but as tom and jeff have both
said we're also well aware of the
politics particularly in an election
year or in a government transition
period so um these are really really
difficult problems to address and it's
not just a problem in a pandemic
we see this problem for more mundane
problems as well one of the places where
i think we we may be able to learn some
lessons is from the global fund
as well as in its intersection with the
world bank that part of the opportunity
here is to leverage financing so that we
create the mechanisms and the the pull
to be able to um
require this kind of global access
and and the last point i'll make as i
feel so strongly about it is that as
we're seeing vaccine supply improve
certainly not where it needs to be but
certainly improved
it isn't just about the number of doses
it's about the systems and the ability
for
people to establish immunization
programs which in most parts of the
world there is no such thing as an adult
immunization program so to suddenly flex
and try to immunize you know not infants
but adults and teenagers of multiple
ages that's a heavy lift in a crisis so
if we're thinking about how to improve
supply we need to probably make sure we
don't forget to improve the ability to
distribute and
trust the value of the supply that we
are talking about lots of work to do
here i'm not trying to be pessimistic
i'm just saying that i i think i have a
pretty sober outlook on the lift that we
need to get together and and really try
to try to support
wonderful so so um the next question is
actually from
a former new york city department of
health um infectious epidemiologist so
naturally i'll ask dr frieden
[Music]
well i can ask either of you any of you
um
you were well qualified to answer that
question but i'll focus this one on you
um
and the question is the do you have any
ideas about how to rebuild
and reinforce the public health
workforce
post covet 19. there's a lot of burnout
there's a lot of
despondence in terms of
you know despite a lot of hard work
there is a decline in trust uh you know
and we have to recognize that uh before
addressing it and so the other one part
is the overall workforce from a health
department perspective from a federal
agency perspective but the other aspect
of the question i would add
is that often academic entities
don't do a good job and we have to be or
at least as good a job and we have to be
honest about
is to be responsive to the needs of
applied public health for public health
we shouldn't be in the business of
creating facsimiles of of uh tenured
professors in the field of public health
uh we need to be in the business of
creating consequentialist public health
um practitioners as well
and so so any thoughts um
from that because you've led a
non-governmental organization a health
department as well as cdc
what can we do better
first i think it's important not to
[Music]
not to either under or overestimate the
problem
yes there are people are exhausted it's
been two years plus
um in many parts of the country and
world public health has been quite
literally under attack and
uh yes there are a lot of people who are
tired um
and
have left the field or considered
leaving the field already it was an
older workforce that was nearing
retirement
that's why we created new programs like
the public health associates program at
cdc to bring early career people into
public health
i think first off we have to get the
funding for public health right
this is crucially important
as
president biden said when he was vice
president you show me your budget i'll
show you your values
and
that's why we're advocating for a health
defense operations budget designation
that would give people in public health
uh confidence that it's not going to be
that boom and bust panic neglect cycle
it's going to be sustainable funding not
just for their salaries but for the
programs that they're running so that
they can rely on the ability to start a
program continue it and see it to
improvement and and progress this is
crucially important i think on one hand
on the other hand i think all public
agencies
really need to think about how to make
the job rewarding and safe for the
workers and that means
that you
are able to
have and show impact that gives people
huge satisfaction
it is it is
wonderfully
inspiring to work in public health but
you have to be able
to see the the faces and the lives
behind the numbers because the people
whose lives you save will not know that
you save their life so you have to be
able to be satisfied by the actual
calculation
of what the impact has been you also
have to
continuously upgrade people's skills
we're all learning all the time and that
makes jobs more satisfying and you have
to have a work environment that that is
supportive um and uh
um is able to
contribute to people's sense of personal
worth personal efficacy so i i think
although there's a lot of media
attention and it's true
that there are a lot of people who are
tired and leaving public health it's
also true as you know that public health
is
very very popular as an interest in
colleges and universities that this can
be a time of public health renaissance
where we diversify the field where we
get into areas that are more effective
that we go deeply into communities to
identify
as we do in all of our programs
what is the art of the possible in each
community and in each time and that
becomes an enormously satisfying job so
i would say
by all means we have to keep people in
public health resourced safe supported
part of a broader network
nationally globally even
and at the same time recognize that it
is a wonderful career with the
opportunity to uh make a difference and
help to improve protect save literally
millions of lives
no you're absolutely right and i
sometimes say to my students that and
training is that the easiest way to or
to avoid a mid-life crisis or
existential angst um that a lot of
people talk about is to go into public
health the job public health can be
frustrating underpaid uh tiring but it
is never never ever meaningless uh it is
always what you do has has meaning
um
so i will sort of end we as we come
towards uh the end of our conversation
and i'll say that we're getting a ton of
questions i have uh not even
asked you
a third of the questions we are getting
because we have multiple streams i see a
question streaming
besides because we are going on facebook
live as well and so i'm getting uh sort
of uh questions that someone is taking
there from there as well and and and
then more direct questions uh as well so
so i apologize uh to our audience for
not getting to most of your questions
but but uh i don't think anyone wants a
three-hour
sort of program but i will come back to
the same format i'll ask the same
question
from each of you
cdc is a national treasure and
um
and yes
we need to recognize
that it has taken a hit a lot of it
unfairly but also a lot of
lessons need to be learned i'll tell you
that we at yale the institute for global
health did the first survey in this
national survey of attitudes in this
pandemic on february 8
2020 and when we asked people who would
you like to hear from
in terms of the response the top one not
the president not the nih director not
before well before dr fauci became a
household name it was the cdc director
people did not know the name of the cdc
director
and so that's the cachet the baseline
caches cdc has and we can return to that
the question
i am i was asked most frequently to ask
you is each of you briefly
how do we restore uh trust in the cdc so
we'll go in the reverse order so we'll
start with dr frieden dr gruberding and
dr copeland
i think the cdc needs to speak directly
to the american people regularly from
atlanta
not part of washington or white house
briefing and
trust is built teaspoon at a time and
lost bucketful at a time so it's going
to take time but success breeds success
and the more cdc is able to do great
work and show the great work it's doing
that it hasn't been able to show i think
you can steadily rebuild that trust
julie
i agree with tom i i certainly think
that the credibility of anyone at cdc is
improved by communicating from the cdc
and not from a political institution
but i also think that it's important to
realize that the cdc is not
convincing the world that the director
is science-based or even that the cdc is
science-based i think we need to reflect
the public health system as a whole and
so in addition to having the director
who i i think our current cdc director
is an outstanding
spokesperson
i i i think it's important that we hear
directly from the scientists as often as
that's possible that they're standing on
the podium as information is being
communicated that they address the
specific scientific questions but i also
think it's important that other public
health leaders
in our network are also part of the
conversation so it doesn't look like
something has come down from the
mountain and is being disseminated to
the valley but rather that our public
health system together is strong we're
on the same page we're collaborating and
coming up with you know the
interpretation of the science but also
as tom said earlier the practical
matters and and that when we stand
together we can also explain why maybe
we're going to do one thing right now in
this community and a community over here
may be in a different situation or have
a different judgment and that's okay
we're still all starting from the same
platform of science but it will be a
long slog to build the credibility of
the cdc back up and i think that's where
all of us who our stakeholders in this
need to help i think we we can endorse
the things that have gone well and try
to be helpful and constructive about the
things where we think some improvement
might be useful
brother copeland
you know just continuing what uh dr
gerberting was saying um
at the best times in public health has
been when we have robust local and
municipal and state health departments
working well with federal partners
and that's fallen apart a bit
and
[Music]
the need for
commonality of interest and a visible
partnership right through the system
from
grassroots
to cdc director
needs to be reinstituted in a way that
people see it understand it and value it
the point is has been made that there's
a lot
a number of things went wrong in this
investigation and probably well into the
future we're dealing with a largely
unknown scientific entity have made
great advances in the course of it um
but
as you won ventures ahead you know we're
not batting a hundred a thousand
on this thing nor will we ever
um
i think the the
kind of attitude nationally and it's not
shared by everyone obviously
nevertheless
uh takes i think an unfairly critical
uh look at cdc
uh in a way that doesn't serve any of us
well and
if there's
bath water that needs to be thrown out
fine but be careful what what one you're
what you're messing with in the
institution the institution has more
talented brilliant
contributing scientifically monitored
people people than any institution in
the world and that includes
distinguished schools of public health
at universities
and it needs to be nourished and it has
to be seen for its good
aspects
um
i think your attention is going to have
to be paid
towards funding and that doesn't mean
cutting funding it means providing
sufficient predictable flexible funding
again from the grassroots level right up
um those the people on the field
need to be working closely with cdc and
vice versa cdc needs to be listening to
folks in state health departments and
always has in the past
workforce needs to be improved new
skills
focused on data and analytics and
communication
and with it is needed better pay and
incentives and increase diversity in the
workforce it makes a difference in
improvement programs and outcomes
the data issues are real
uh that they couple with the science as
dr gerbering indicated and dr frieden
has demonstrated over and over again in
his career but data drives things and we
need some common measures it's really
inconceivable that we're unable to get
common measures from state to state to
federal
this undermines what we're trying to do
and that needs to be corrected um
political influence has been mentioned
it could be good or it can be bad
let's try to play out the good parts and
value of
politics in what we do
communication is
extraordinarily important cdc needs a
top quality lead in that
and
a
office
that is
21st century
in delivering messages experts in social
media etc
so
thanks sure this is an opportunity to
improve and a crisis like this maybe get
something much stronger at the end we
certainly hope so
um
i think
we are
we are still in the midst of a pandemic
uh
going to the beach and not
wearing a
mask
being in close quarters
lots of things are not history they're
not part of the past of this pandemic
unfortunately they're still part of the
pandemic
so there'll be an ongoing key role for
the likes of us and other people in
public health and for its institutions
and the
more of those institutions can do their
mission the better off everybody in this
country will be and and potentially in
the world
thank you with that i'll uh close our
session and i want to thank all three of
you for being uh here and engaging and
engaging in this conversation hopefully
uh next time around uh you know we'll
we'll have the pleasure of hosting you
either individually or together as well
in person and you'll get the big benefit
of being in person is that you get to
interact with the
the most inspiring and smartest members
of the yale community which is our
students and early stage faculty so with
that i'll close this conversation and
i'll remind our
um sort of audiences that we you know
stay tuned to the next uh conversation
series event uh which is uh
which is likely to be equally exciting
so um appreciate all three of you and
everyone else who has attended and those
of uh of of us uh and members of the ygh
team um that that helped make
this
conversation series possible thank you
thank you thank you thank you very much
take care